afternoon everyone and welcome to
today's and Android developer interview
today we are fortunate enough to be
joined by the good folks from pocket
gems we've got Arjun and Jeff from the
pocket gems team here today to talk a
little bit about their products and
their experience developing on Android
you're particularly going to share a
little bit about their experience in
defragging the Android developer well
defrag Android development I should say
so we do these developer interviews
hopefully regularly would really
appreciate you appreciate your feedback
to find out what we could be doing
differently how we can be making this a
better experience for you guys so uh
Arjun do you want to tell us a little
bit about pocket gems and what you could
be talking about tonight yeah great
thanks very - so Jeff and I are here
today from packages were really excited
to be at Google and we wanted to really
the purpose of this is to share all the
knowledge that we've learned over the
past year with our Android development
and give you know any developer out
there tips and tricks on how they can
optimize their development and get the
best user experience out there so let's
get started so the title of our talk is
entitled defragging your Android
development and essentially you know we
call it a defragging your development
because you know there's this notion
that there's a lot of fragmentation on
Android and we hear this a lot from you
know developers that we work with and we
really wanted to kind of debunk some of
the myths and talk about some of the
tips and tricks that we've learned to
make that process much easier so just so
my name is urgent dial on the product
lead of Android app package and I come
from a computer science background got
my degree at MIT and before this I
worked on Xbox Kinect and I'm Jeff Q I
did robotics at Olin College of
Engineering and then went and worked for
Blue Origin an aerospace company as a
software developer before I moved down
to Pocket gems great so for those of you
that don't know a whole lot about taça
gems we were founded in 2009 and we are
a mobile gaming company on both iOS and
Android so we currently have 14 titles
or a Sequoia back company and
essentially you know we've been a
pioneer in the free-to-play mobile game
space so we have the first farm game we
have the first store game we have the
first hotel again
and very recently we also pioneered the
first exploration simulation game and so
you know what makes us really excited
about Android and you know why we're
giving this talk is because just the
numbers have just been really
ridiculously amazing and so if you were
at GDC what you saw was you know the
stats that said there's more than 300
million activations to date on Android
there's more than 850,000 new
activations per day and there's already
over you know a billion app installs per
month and now with the you know the new
Google Play system it's essentially
you've got a one-stop shop for all of
your entertainment experiences it makes
it a lot easier as a developer for you
to get the right experience to the right
users so bottom line it's a huge
opportunity for for you as a developer
and you know the market is just really
exciting right now so for pocket gems in
particular we currently have four titles
on Android with plans for many many more
to come and so we have Tatsu currently
which was the number one grossing iOS
game in 2011 along with you know two of
our more our latest titles Tapley ever
after and the one that is an Android
exclusive right now tap Safari and so
this is just a start for us we're really
excited about you know the growth of
Android and the growth of the market
itself and we're looking forward to
putting more games out exclusively on
Android so wanted to jump into a couple
of things that are they're really
important about game development and the
first one as a developer which I'm sure
you've realized is that making games
isn't as easy as you might think it is
that at the start so not only do you
have to have a killer game concept
intuitive UI and engaging art you also
have to decide between do you want to
have a paid app or would you like to use
in-app purchase and then you know
thinking about the future you want to
think about how well the backend
services are to scale to the millions of
users that you're going to have when
your game is you know a hit but not only
do you have to consider those things but
there's also things that you might have
forgotten about and so essentially what
you the things that you might forget
about our memory performance and the
different devices and what you should
prioritize as being the you know your
focal points as well as regions on the
locale and so all of these combined you
know should be taken into a
when you're thinking about your Android
game development and in order to create
a successful experience and so I'm going
to give a couple of tips on basically
some things that we've learned and and
jump right into that the first thing is
it's important to pick the right set of
devices that you want to really tailor
your game to and and I guess tell you
step back at what Android really
provides as an opportunity to with a
single development process reach a huge
variety of devices the Android platform
is so diverse and so and so great but
you can't just hit publish and get a
game to work on every single device it
does take a little work and you got to
step through it and so what we suggest
is pick a few devices that you really
want to focus your QA on and do most of
your of your testing on and and picking
those devices definitely comes down to
who who are the users that you're most
interested in demographics of people who
have those devices and there's a ton of
information available online about the
breadth and the adoption of particular
devices that can help you make that
those decisions and but it's important
to keep in mind that there are times
when you just won't be able to support
every device and often it's better to
just leave a device off your approved
list rather than give people a subpar
experience next thing is just the screen
resolution it can really it's it's a
tricky issue but you know there there
are really high res phones and tablets
and low res phones as well and you know
you definitely want to want to do
everything you can to support all those
but sometimes it's important to just
restrict your apps so that it only goes
out to the devices that you have had
time to develop for so far but keeping
in mind that you always want to go back
and make sure as many users as possible
have accessed here to your application
one one thing that we found particularly
interesting is that you can't just focus
on the pixel resolution of a device
because there are 10 inch tablets and 4
inch phones that have exactly the same
screen resolution and and that can cause
a pretty jarring difference for users if
you're writing your code to just pay
attention to those pixels so definitely
know the know those limits and and keep
that keep that in mind when you're
developing your apps for us at pocket
gems taking advantage of our tools has
been really important I mean obviously
having scripted builds is sort of a
no-brainer in software development but
it's it's been really important for us
especially when we're interacting with
our QA team to make sure that any build
that they're that they're doing tests on
has been produced using a very reliable
process we use a continuous integration
system to make sure that we're always
getting the same results every time we
turn out a build and we don't do any QA
work on builds that are produced from an
IDE we save we reuse the ide builds
solely for the development iteration
before we before we call a feature
complete and another great tool that
we've really really latched onto is
called robolectric it's a open source
tool that it really makes it's a testing
framework for Android that really makes
testing so much easier it does it makes
unit testing and integration testing
just the breeze and and we've used it to
speed up our development process really
really significantly another great thing
that we have is we've added a cheat menu
to our games so that user sorry so that
our QA teams have the ability to jump
through the game so they can make sure
that when we have a bug or a problem
later in the game they can jump right to
it and they don't have to play through
the whole game every time
it's also a good way to sort of
experiment with new features so one of
the other one of the other great things
no this is you great so you know one of
the problems that's actually classic
Android that we'd like to illustrate
here it's you know once you essentially
finished creating your game and you're
ready to put it through a real rigorous
testing schedule and make sure that it's
ready to go out right you'll you'll
classically fall into this problem where
you say okay I have a thousand devices
which are the devices that I should
prioritize and what are actually the
operating systems that I want to make
sure that I have you know a really
polished experience on and so the way
that we think about this at pocket jams
is essentially in this matrix view and
so in a sense you'll see for example
we've got some devices on the left-hand
side the galaxy ace the Droid X the
Galaxy Nexus and these might be things
that again we've identified as target
devices or are apt to go out on and it
could be based on you know GPU it could
be based on memory it could be based on
you know CPU cycles but essentially we
picked and prioritized the device list
that we want and then at that point you
know we know that each of these devices
runs on a number of different operating
systems so if we want it to be a hundred
percent certain that we were you know
going to have an amazing experience on
every single device and every
configuration what we would do is start
to check off each one of these boxes and
spend time performing a full test pass
on the galaxy ace with - 1 - 2 404 a 3
same thing with you know say the lg
optimus going through this entire thing
but as you can realize when you you know
this is only 5 or 6 devices when you
start to expand this out to between 10
and 20 devices it becomes a solution
that you know you don't have enough time
essentially to QA your device and all
these so really the what I'd like to
propose and how we think about this is
instead of feeling that like you have to
perform a full QA pass on everything
make sure that you have coverage across
every operating system and across every
device that you care about and you can
priorities prioritize these a little
different based on how you view the
importance of each device but in this
case if you'll see
like to test the galaxy ace on two point
one we'd like to test the Galaxy Nexus
on the latest for three and now in this
sense we have a testing process every
one of our devices that we care about
and across you know every operating
system that it could that we also care
about and so what you'll see here is
again you haven't you're not forming the
or you're not performing the full
complete QA pass over all these but this
is you know from a risk perspective a
great way to think about optimizing your
time and especially if you don't have
you know if you have limited resources
so another way to think about this is
that after you've shipped your app you
should really be using the data and the
analytics that you're receiving from
Google or your own collection to refine
your process so in this case if I find
that once I release I'm making 90
percent of my revenue from 4'o devices
and maybe the galaxy tab on 3.1 then
it's completely fine to go back and
alter your QA process and say instead of
you know testing on tu1 and tu2 anymore
I'm really going to focus all my efforts
on 400 devices for all these to make
sure that I have a hundred percent
success rate in terms of the experience
going out so again it's it's going to be
on a case-by-case basis but it's
completely okay to go and refine these
afterwards too for your specific needs
so now again when you're thinking about
keyway a lot of people are asking well
do I run a full test pass and everything
like what does that actually mean do I
run a broad test which is what we would
call compatibility test and so for us
from the matrix if you remember we would
perform a full test pass on a select
number of devices and so that might be
the Galaxy Nexus on 403 and the galaxy
tab on 3.0 but we would also perform a
compatibility test which essentially
touches every feature but doesn't go
nearly into the depth that a full test
pass would so you know compatibility
test for us would take maybe minutes for
each device instead of the hours that it
takes you to perform a full test pass
and make sure every single scenario and
every quest and every feature is 100%
you know polished and again I would
think about prioritizing what to run
based on those popular devices either
for your game or in the market if you
haven't shipped that out it's also
important to remember
that it's okay to test to the deltas so
when you're you know you're trying to be
very agile in Android Android has this
great ability that when you publish your
app it goes live immediately and so you
do have the ability to say okay if I've
made a targeted change to maybe just one
or two sections of the code you don't
need to go back and run maybe a full
test pass across all of your devices
wheat but what you could do is run you
know a targeted test pass to just the
areas of the code that you identify that
you have deltas in and essentially what
how we think about this is it's all
about risk from a risk perspective
you're going to ship out builds to your
users you want to have the highest
confidence that what you're shipping out
is the highest quality so your users
have a great experience but with you
know the limited time and resources that
you know as a developer you're going to
have it's really important to prioritize
effectively and reduce the risk as much
as possible yeah I mean personally one
of the things that is most fun about
being a developer at pocket gems is just
the ability to work in this really tight
feedback loop between QA and the
developers you know we're all in the
same area and we all get to talk you
know all the time and it's just a really
important part of how we make the games
better is just every time we make a
feature change we're having a discussion
about how that improves the gameplay and
the flow and and QA is always there to
keep us honest but but that's just a
build process and when we release and
transition into live ops is when we
start sort of opening up the doors for
the whole second part of the the process
which is where we take the crash reports
and the the analytics and the data that
we're collecting from our users playing
the games and what they're enjoying and
we start to take that and feed that back
into both our development process and
our QA process to improve both so that
overall our build process just gets
significantly better and that's it's a
really important point in the
development phase of a project is where
you transition to all of a sudden having
these this broad and and really rich set
of data that you
what your users are doing the way that
we do that most is by by taking
advantage of any time there is a crash
or an error on a device we make sure we
report as much data as we can back to
our servers so that we can really you
know grind through that data we you know
of course whenever there's a crash we
want a stack trace of where in the code
path the application was but we also
have info stacks which give us more
content data about what was actually
being processed when the error occurred
and that's you know a really really
valuable thing especially when you run
it through the same code and tons of
different ways but the you know and on
our servers we have automatic
deification which is just really
powerful for us time-saving lies we have
the ability to report in our crash
reports the last 50 lines of log data
that we push to to our log and that's
just a really great way to get the
context of what generally was the
application up to even if it what are
the crashes that are happening most
often and that's a really important
thing for us as a development team and
management you know from management
perspective just figuring out what is
the top priority and and then but
sometimes you know you you end up with a
crash that you don't have all the
information for and you have to make a
choice at that point are you going to
move on as a team and just live with
that crash for for a while until maybe
you just kind of stumble upon a solution
or what we end up having to do more
often is add to the instrumentation that
your application provides add new
features into your crash reports I mean
a lot of these features that you've seen
here because of that kind of a narration
we needed better tools and so you know a
lot of the time you just have to put
that investment in but I would say one
of the greatest things is utilizing
customers
the the customers who go out of their
way to post on a forum or to give a
review are
they've already shown that interest in
your game and there they're there and
they are often so responsive and so
helpful and the dialogue and the depth
of detail you can get is just really
incredible both for the developers and
and especially for the QA team in
finding reproducible bugs so yeah
another trick that we we've gotten our
games is we have sort of a tiered
experience where if you are a developer
building on in your IDE or if you're
running tests on your on your on the
code directly the game anytime it runs
across an unusual situation something
that we flagged is important it'll crash
and that's really important that the
developers don't get to sort of live
with a mild bug like that you know they
sort of are halted in their steps and
they go and they fix it as soon as
possible but you know then the second
tier is when we have our QA team testing
you it would be great if we could just
crash but you know they need to actually
get there their testing done so instead
we pop up a dialog in the game and we
say hey here's the problem that happened
file a bug let the let the dev team know
and that's just really really helpful
for us as a dev team to be able to call
those things out but for users
they don't pay that a bug happened you
know they just want to keep playing the
game so we don't interrupt them at all
what we do send ourselves a crash report
to to allow us to debug that in the
future and especially marked as
something that the user is able to
continue from and so that's our our
tiered system that's worked out really
well for us all right so one final thing
we'd like to touch on is just you know
the potential of Android as a new you
know Ice Cream Sandwich continues to you
know be pushed out into the market a lot
of people are adopting it because
personally his pocket gems we're looking
at these features and get really excited
about the potential for a lot of these
new areas and including Android Beam and
resizable widgets and just the the depth
at which the Google
integration is happening it really is
something that you know as a company and
as a developer you should continue to
look out for because you know in the
next couple months you know that kind of
forward these 4.0 functionality and
features will get rolled out to more
customers so you definitely want to be
ahead of that curve and make sure that
you're able to put out you know an
amazing app to to lost different
customers that's differentiated great so
that's you know we hope you really
enjoyed the tips and tricks that we've
learned over the last year we've been
really happy to come to Google and get
this talk and some questions absolutely
so thanks a lot guys that was was really
interesting quite helpful to get a bit
of insight as to how other development
teams go about developing for Android so
we've we've opened it up to you guys so
if you are watching this hangout and if
you are in the Android developers
serpent's you should be able to join us
so check your string we've also got a
moderator link which we've posted out a
couple of times today so if you do have
a question you'd like to share please
please pop it in there and join us live
in the Hangout and we'd like to hear
your questions in the meantime I've put
together a couple of questions
you guys to kick us off so you talked a
little bit about this within your
presentation but how did you guys decide
which of those devices are the most
important so you said you know focus on
the one from each version the ones that
you're going to you how do you figure
that out yeah that's that's a great
question and essentially we started with
just market data and this was when we
were just new to the to the market and
Android development as well we looked up
the stats and and saw hey you know some
of the the Galaxy phones and something
like that Motorola droids have a
significant market share and so we knew
that for our games our philosophy is to
push out our experiences to you know
everyone and in a sense we want to have
the the largest target audience possible
so we started there with that kind of
device that and then we refined it over
time as we push out apps and we'd see
where our games were working well and
devices where they weren't going well
and so we've had like a year's worth of
experience refining that and coming down
to a set that we feel really comfortable
with and how did you feel that you need
to go back to sort of revise that list
yeah it's a it's an interesting time
because you know you'll see if she see
and Samsung and all these you know
handset makers are releasing so many
things at you know every quarter and so
it's it's definitely advantageous to you
to keep up on a lot of that news and
you'll start to see there's a lot of
sites out there that track Android phone
usage and trends and so say something
for right now I looked at Galaxy s2 is
something that's very popular is risen
quickly over the last couple months so
just keeping track of you know the
market using the stats that Google
provides you as well because you'll see
like what's the most popular device type
and this the most popular operating
system that's a great way to keep track
of it nice so you mentioned that you've
got your own crash reporting system
which is impressive haha so I'd like to
dig a little bit deeper into that if
possible you know how can you talk a
little bit about the implementation side
of that how do you provide that sort of
multi tier level of being able to have
users continue to do their thing and
still do crash reports yeah so a lot of
that is we've built a lot of utilities
inside the client inside the application
to you know what we always want to do is
make sure that in indicate in an
unexpected case if we do run across one
of those code paths we want to figure
out a way to recover safely so you know
that's returning null or returning an
empty object instead of one that that
actually has the functionality you need
that's you know the kind of the kind of
decision you make when you're when
you're developing that but we we have
built in just the utilities to say throw
an exception if you're testing and it's
all nicely wrapped up so that so that
really you just have to make that that
first step as a developer yes this is
one of those points where I do want to
throw an exception if you're you know
send a crash report if I'm a user so
that's our yeah that's how that happens
are you the on the server side it's sort
of a lot simpler or in terms of the
there's a lot less decision-making every
time we get a crash report
run through it see if it fits and
matches with any of the other ones we
have if it does we put put that into a
group otherwise we leave it as an
individual report so you really it's
really brought from the design
perspective right at the beginning you
have to build that right into your app
like you need to throw an exception it's
not good enough to just print it out in
the logs and move on and die you really
need to figure out how can it continue
even after this unexpected cases as it
could yeah absolutely yeah we try and
start with that philosophy every time we
add a new feature yeah it's really
important because then on the other hand
you will still get crash reports where
you don't have enough information and so
at that point you make a decision you
say how much time do I want to spend
investigating this or can I get you know
actionable repro steps in a sense on it
but the other way that you can think
about it is okay well now that I have a
crash that I think I know the area that
it's in you can go back and add some
more logs or instrumentation to those to
get better data for the next actual bill
that you ship out so it's an evolving
process and even we find areas of the
system where we want to get more
information about it so it's a
continuously evolving process for us
very cool very interesting so given that
you have your own crash reporting system
do you still take advantage of the
things which you get provided by the
system like the Android crash reports on
developer console yeah we do and and
that's why it's great because with the
prioritization of the the Android data
itself it helps us also it's another
data point in terms of we see our own
crash groups and we see you know what's
infecting our users but it's just like a
second point of validation on yes this
is the crash that we should really go
spend our time on because you know you
might be getting hundreds of crashes a
day from you know obscure devices that
you didn't even know your your app was
going to and at that point it becomes
you could spend months going back and
trying to track down all these crashes
so you really have to have a very
explicit prioritization system so we use
the Google data from the dashboard
heavily in conjunction with our own data
very cool and you mentioned using the
dotter in the developer console as well
to be able to do that post launch
prioritization of weight when I focused
time and attention
we had the console engineers on a couple
of times over the last few months
talking about their plans for the future
and well talking about trying to get
information from you guys as to what the
what they should be planning so they've
had a few launches since then I'm
curious real-world developers how have
you found that transition you know do
you like the new version of the dev
console and you know
well we'd say the mr. the most useful
yeah I think we've definitely have been
very happy with how that's been evolving
over time and you know for awhile we
didn't have a ton information there you
would see some of these the crash
reports and stack traces but now that
you have info on you know largest
carrier and things like countries and
how your app compares to let the average
say casual app in the market it's just
it's great data that before we didn't
really have access to and we would kind
of be guessing well I think we're you
know overweight in one area versus
another but when you can actually see
that data and start to use it in your
future creation it helps out a lot very
cool so we've been focusing a lot on how
you report things when things go wrong
Gee's analytics that's yeah I think
that's great and you know POC jams our
philosophy is we're very analytical
company we like to make almost all of
our decisions based on data and you know
not you know intuition gets you by 85%
of the way there but then you need that
extra data validation to make sure that
you're doing the right things so we
certainly you know we're heavily
instrument all of our events and so you
know what things people are buying where
they're getting stock you know things
like retention the monetization and
engagement stats and we use those very
heavily to understand how to how to teen
our games and how to make them better
for all of our users out there be cool
yeah I mean people's very much the same
it's very sort of analytical driven
company where you try and get as much
data to base your decisions on possible
so yeah so in terms of it we'll talk a
little bit about how you choose what
devices you want to focus on obviously a
big thing for us these days to tablets
try to get you know developers to seize
the opportunity there and really
optimize the experience for tablets is
there something that's on the radar you
guys
yeah absolutely I mean I would say that
one of the things that we've been
focusing on most recently is making sure
that our games run and look really crisp
on the high-res screens and just
building up you know it's it's one thing
to handle a couple of different aspect
ratios for for some devices that are all
about four or five inches but when you
are you know three five inches but when
you start you know scaling up to the to
the huge tablet displays it really does
require a lot more thought of how how is
the game going to play when all of a
sudden the buttons are three times as
big as your finger you know and the
taking care and and figuring out
strategies of of actually taking into
account the physical width of how big
something is going to be on the screen
rather than just the number of pixels
has been something that I think has
started to show in our inner games and
started to really improve the gameplay
for for all users and in fact one of the
really great side effects of that is
that the more we focus on those really
high res high yeah large screens we
actually have been incidentally and and
once we realize this we really seize the
opportunity improving the experience for
the really low res phones the really
small devices and that's actually been I
think one of a one of the highlights of
our of our past few releases is really
making that experience better for
everyone
outstanding and so I'm from sort of the
conceptual leap to go oh actually this
is something we need to look at and
optimize for how difficult has it been
to sort of implement those changes
provide something custom for the
different sorts of devices I think that
actually the you know with the native
Android UI toolkit for our menus and
things like that it's just been really
quite easy to to start taking advantage
of alternate layouts things like that to
make the game work better in those
different environments but also the you
know for us just thinking about new ways
to to do scaling and an in-game you know
when we have the high art displays that
it's it's sort of a different problem
and figuring out how to build scaling
into those those screens from the start
rather than doing it as an afterthought
has it's it's been a it's actually gone
very smoothly I think once we once we
made that decision to start paying close
attention to scaling we we were able to
tackle the problem pretty easily that's
great it seems a lot less speak to
developers the issue isn't so much being
able to do it but just sort of realizing
that you have to you've got an office
full of people just using standard
phones and then someone comes in with
something really high res or a fancy new
10-inch tablet yeah and a lot of times
what we do is we can we force ourselves
to use different devices so you know I
love my Galaxy Nexus but you know I have
I apportion myself to user laura's
device just to understand what the
experience is you know across the board
and you'll find funny things like well
when you want to optimize for the
high-res devices then all of a sudden
you know the quality of your art needs
to get a little bigger which makes the
image size larger which then you know
translates to apki apki is getting
larger and so it's this you know it's
this balance that you really have to go
through but really at the end of the day
creates a better user experience so it's
something that we're we're really happy
to continue doing yeah it's funny we do
the same thing we'll be testing games
and apps for partners to give people
feedback and we're so used to using the
same devices now my Galaxy Nexus and my
transformer prime and that's a little
I'll do it on and then so we've have to
stop and realize actually a lot of
people aren't using access I should
probably a gingerbread device just for
fun
you mentioned the challenge with you
know supporting more and more devices
that your apk gets bigger and bigger are
you guys still delivering things as a
single apk or if you started to make use
of multi apk delivery yeah so for right
now we're still using mainly just the
one apk
but as you know Ice Cream Sandwich
functionality becomes more prevalent in
the market we're certainly looking at
the idea of moving to multiplied decays
and you can imagine that will even have
to adjust our QA
philosophies and our prioritization
because now you're testing to apks that
might be 90 percent similar but then
again you have these customs this custom
functionality so it's going to be you
know interesting for us as we continue
to move on with you know having multiple
apks because that's the right solution
ultimately and we'll get to see how we
have to modify our processes accordingly
excellent um so I'd be interested to
touch a little bit on your testing and
QA process if possible so how often do
you do releases and what's the process
there in QA and making sure that what
you put out is really high quality I
mean we aim for very frequent releases
for a few weeks or more often impossible
we I mean we do constant constant QA
testing test passes of of our games we
always focus on of course the one for
the QA side what whichever one we're
doing the most development on and and we
do try and sort of cycle through our
games not not spend too much time
looking at looking at just one but
really make sure we're not leaving them
behind but I guess we we always we work
really closely with the QA team to make
sure that they know exactly what we're
changing and try and keep you know keeps
their their jobs much simpler if they
know exactly what to look for what might
go wrong what are the possible side
effects and that's definitely been our
recipe for success is just as a good
communication there between the dev and
QA teams as possible yeah I think as a
company our philosophy is really the day
that we you know ship a game on day one
that's not the end for us you know we
are very committed to our users and
devoted to adding new functionality and
features regularly and you know we found
both on the iOS and Android side that
our users really appreciate that and so
our game you know if you look at tap zoo
from day one versus tap zoo now or you
know tap Safari or tap we're after
you'll see that it goes through you know
massive amounts of change
that you might not expect from a mobile
app developer a lot of times it's once
you're done with the game then let's
move on to the next one but we have you
know a very philosophy that once we push
it out we should also you know listen to
our users and figure out what they want
and where we can take the next leap not
standing you know I always love to speak
to developers we should take that
approach of not just pushing over the
wall and moving on to the next project
but really treating it is not as a
service as such but as a product which
continues to live people it's been a lot
of time and effort on that on adding
games so it's it's useful for them
interesting and it's interesting useful
for them to know that what they're doing
is so the camera isn't switching so
we're going to take it alright so yeah
like I said it's a great to hear that
you guys take that that approach of you
know once it's out there it's something
you need to continue to support and
probably something I need to pay more
attention to on the apps that I put on
the market
she don't always get quite as much love
so let's see so are you releasing your
titles you're not an Android only shop
right you are you release titles another
smartphone platforms can you tell us a
little bit about you know what's your
release strategy for there you prefer
one platform or another trying at least
the same time what's the thing yeah
that's a great question and so you know
when we when the company was founded you
know iOS platform was the most mature at
the time and so we having limited
resources focused our efforts primarily
on iOS so that's how we you know grew
our our operations and that's where you
know the majority of our time was spent
but you know as Android has ramped up
and has become an amazing market with a
lot of opportunity we've also shifted
our resources and our efforts to
creating not only you know things like
simultaneous releases but also looking
at the potential of Android first and
Android exclusive type launches so as
you know the market continued
two ball we recognize that both
margaret's are actually different you
can't treat them the same
you can't necessarily push the exact
same app out on both platforms and
expect it to do well on both so we're
taking the approach of tailoring our
experiences to you know the custom
platforms it's interesting have you
found that that's being effective you
know producing slightly different
versions does that resulted in you know
without going into too much detail but
is that resulted in more relative
revenue to know than just the same yeah
you know it's interesting and again like
we take a very analytical approach to
this we will try different features and
different aspects on each platform and
we'll be able to see what the ROI is of
that so it's um you know you can start
it you know as a developer if you have
an iOS game you know it might be great
to if you wanted to move over to Android
start with feature parity but then as
you start to look at the data and see
everything that's coming in you'll
realize that you will need to tune it
and add custom features for your Android
audience in order to potentially get the
same or better you know return from it
yeah it's interesting it's something
which we've been telling developers for
a while like you know your Android
audience have different expectations
yeah I think particularly for
development shops which have come from
an iOS background or even a different
smartphone background and have those
devices you know they are users of that
platform and so they have the same
expectations
whereas the vast majority of their
audience hasn't had a different device
or has chosen an Android device for a
reason right so there's definitely an
advantage I think to really customizing
your solution to something that your
actual users will be happy with yeah
it's interesting let's see we've got
time for a couple more questions I'm
just having a look on the moderator I
think we've got anything there which is
particularly is there anything there
that you're inclined to answer this
questions about competitors and and
revenue which I don't think you guys
will answer he talked about how many
developers that you've got sure so you
know it's one of those things where our
team evolves over time and you know as
we create more Android exclusives and
more titles for our Symington
simultaneous launches so it's not
something that you know is ever static
and so we change that over time just
based on
where we want to put resources the the
in-app purchase one so the question is
how well is in-app purchase gone for tap
two you know as the again a company
philosophy of ours is to have a we
follow the freemium model and not the
the paid model because we really wanted
to reduce that barrier to entry for
everyone to come and try out our
experience and so for us it has gone
really well and you know we don't have
comparable data or to say like what
would happen if taps we was a paid app
or things like that but it's just our
company philosophy has been let's get it
out to the most amount of users as
possible so they can all enjoy it sure
that makes sense now
so um let's have a look so I think we've
got any other questions coming
you just have a quick look on the G+
stream to see whether anyone has asked
them there what do you ask by using for
crash reporting we've gone through that
okay so you can probably just about wrap
up what I am interested in I don't know
how much you can talk about it but do
you have more on the horizon for Android
we've seen all the theories or have you
guys got more plan yeah you certainly
have not seen all that there is on
Android from pocket gems just yet we're
excited to be working on another Android
exclusive title that we'll be able to
talk about and you know in a couple
weeks but we're excited it's going to be
an Android first that's great news and
early exclusive well definitely be
looking forward to that and yeah might
get you guys on again maybe to join us
on the Friday review to to talk about
once it's released alright well thank
you both very much for joining stay into
the presentation and yeah hopefully
we'll we'll see you guys again shortly
and oh yeah
thanks everyone fellows for joining us
so we do Android developer office hours
every Wednesday at 2:00 and we have the
Friday review for two hours between 1:00
and 3:00 every Friday and we'll
hopefully be doing more of these
developer interviews on Thursdays at 2
o'clock again so if there are people who
would like to have behind the table on
the hot seat do let us know and we will
reach out to them and see if we can get
to come in and answer a few questions
so until then thank you very much
you